for the first time in nearly 30 years a
person was killed on a film set after
being accidentally shot is alec baldwin
going to jail
[Music]
the camera crew was setting up for a
shot when alec baldwin put his hand on
the colt 45 revolver in its holster and
said so i guess i'm gonna take this out
pull it out and go bang what followed
was shock and confusion as baldwin
pulled the gun out of its holster a lead
bullet exploded from the muzzle hitting
director of photography helena hutchins
who tumbled backwards director joel
souza also hit the ground when the
bullet exited hutchinson's body and
embedded in his shoulder what the f just
happened that was the question baldwin
repeated over and over again a 911
caller alerted the dispatcher that there
was trouble on set the nasa creek ranch
has had two people accidentally shot on
a movie set by a prop gun we need help
immediately oh bonanza creek rant come
on so was it loaded with a real bullet
or one i don't i cannot tell you that
okay hutchins death sent shock waves to
the entertainment industry which had
just averted a crippling strike by film
industry workers hollywood tv and film
crews were still reeling from a 2014
train accident that killed sarah jones
and injured eight others her death and
now the loss of helena hutchins are
raising serious questions about
workplace safety on film and tv
productions
so today we're going to talk about who
is responsible for what happened on the
set of rust could there be criminal
penalties could alec baldwin face
manslaughter charges and what about the
armorer and assistant director who were
responsible for checking the guns now an
important standard disclaimer here we
don't know what happened on the set of
this film we don't know what actions
people took or did not take a lot of
that will come as a result of the
criminal investigation which appears to
be in process so a lot of this video is
going to be speculative based on
hypotheticals of what may have happened
so don't jump to any conclusions here a
lot of this information is going to
change and a lot more information is
going to come to light but first let's
talk about this movie itself rust is an
upcoming western written and directed by
joel souza it stars alec baldwin travis
fimmel and jensen ackles the plot
follows a 13 year old boy who goes on
the run with his grandpa after the boy
is sentenced to hang for an accidental
killing the los angeles times has the
most updated reconstruction of what
happened on the russ set their timeline
is based on interviews with 14 members
of the crew official statements by the
parties involved in the search warrant
affidavits the events that led up to the
shooting started at 6 10 a.m on thursday
when six members of the camera crew
walked off the set before the day's
filming got started their resignations
came after a week of complaints about
unsatisfactory working conditions
including a lack of safety on set in the
days before the camera crew quit
hutchins had tried to resolve some of
their complaints by forfeiting a half
day's rental of a technocrane equipment
that enables photographers to get aerial
shots she hoped that by sacrificing part
of her budget the producers could spend
the money on closer lodging for the crew
the lodging problem was so serious that
it became a running joke someone ordered
custom t-shirts that read error 404
housing not found on wednesday the night
before the shooting jonas huerta the
digital utility technician wrote an
email outlining his safety concerns
quote i also feel anxious on set i've
seen first hand our assistant director
david halls rushed to get shots and he
skips over important protocols he often
rushes to shoot i've had more than a few
occasions where i've been close to the
weapons being fired with no regards to
my hearing sometimes he rushes so
quickly that props hasn't even had the
chance to bring ear plugs and he rolls
and the actors fire anyway just 10 hours
later hutchins was surprised to find the
camera crew was leaving as she tearfully
hugged the camera operators line
producer gabrielle pickle told the
camera operators to pick up the pace and
get off the set she threatened to call
security on them that's when david halls
interrupted the scene to rush hutchins
away saying that they needed to prepare
for the day baldwin's call time was 7 54
am at 8am the crew had a safety meeting
after a few hours they completed the
first shot lunch was called property
master sarah zachary retrieved the guns
that would be needed for the scene from
a truck where the weapons were stored
inside a locked safe the ammunition was
also in the truck but had been left
unsecured on a cart during the break
crew members told the la times that
baldwin was pretty concerned about
safety on the set when baldwin rehearsed
this shot a few days earlier quote he
wanted to know where i would be standing
when he drew his gun apparently the
camera technician told him he'd be
standing in a different spot and he said
good however before the fatal shot was
fired there was apparently a major
security breach david halls told
investigators that his typical onset
safety protocols included him checking
the gun barrel for obstructions before
the armorer opens up the hatch of the
weapon and spins the drum hulls told
investigators that reed performed a
safety check with a colt 45 in front of
halls although he thought he saw three
rounds inside the gun he did not check
them before taking the weapon in his
hand this is apparently a serious breach
in safety protocols which require more
than one person to check the gun halls
then ran through baldwin's blocking
himself pulling the gun from the holster
three times without incident he did not
however pull the trigger and before
baldwin was ready to film he wanted to
do a quick rehearsal while the director
and hutchins lined up for the shot
evidently halls is the person who handed
the gun to baldwin and early reports
from the set indicated that hull's
yelled cold gun before giving the weapon
to baldwin however new evidence
indicates that this might not be true
now hulls and reed are pointing the
finger at each other reed says that
hull's handed the gun to baldwin yelling
cold gun but he claims that she was the
one who yelled cold gun
other crew members remember reed being
the one who told baldwin the gun was
actually cold meaning it held blanks
however if someone had double checked
the rounds they probably would have
realized that they weren't blank so
visual inspection would have showed that
at least one lacked the small hole or
indent that visually differentiates
dummies from bullets they also would
have noticed that it didn't make the
signature rattling that proves that
there's only bbs and no gunpowder in the
dummy round but admittedly these are
small details which is why productions
rely on experts and firearms rather than
performers to do the checks but the end
result is that when baldwin started to
rehearse his quick draw he pulled the
trigger and then watched helplessly as
the bullet hit hutchins several reports
say that after the shooting baldwin
repeatedly explained that he had never
been given a hot gun a firearm with live
rounds on set but who has responsibility
for gun safety on set well as you can
imagine the use of firearms on set is
subject to stringent safety standards
according to the website for the santa
fe chapter of the iatsc the union for
film workers an armorer must be on set
when any weapons or firearms are used
quote armors liaise with the director of
photography to determine which camera
angles will minimize any risk of injury
during rehearsals armorers coach the
actors in the correct use of the
firearms explaining possible dangers and
every armorer and prop expert who has
spoken since the accident says that
productions don't use real guns with
live rounds anymore except in extremely
rare circumstances the use of live
rounds would probably need to be
approved by the insurance company ahead
of time and the first news reports
indicated the rust set used prop guns
with dummy ammo sheriff adam mendoza and
district attorney mary carmack altwies
have now spoken about the case for the
first time although the investigation is
ongoing the d.a declared the gun did
fire a live lead round the bullet was
removed from the director's shoulder
this is a serious problem since you can
imagine live rounds are rarely used on a
film set anonymous crew members told the
media that people were shooting tin cans
with prop guns on the morning of the
homicide and there's a possibility that
the prop guns were loaded with live ammo
and no one checked the guns after lunch
mendoza said that the gun was a long
colt revolver quote it's a suspected
live round that was fired but it did
fire from the weapon and it did cause
the injury that would lead us to believe
that it was a live round mendoza
confirmed that there was a complacency
towards weapons safety while the da said
that criminal charges may be filed
against the responsible parties asked
about the possibility that alec baldwin
will face charges the d.a said quote no
one has been ruled out investigators
have collected about 500 rounds of
ammunition including blanks detectives
recovered two boxes of ammo loose ammo
and boxes as well as a quote fanny pack
with ammo along with several spent
casings evidence will be sent to the fbi
crime lab in quantico virginia for
analysis a prop gun is not a toy tv and
film crews typically use specially
designed blank firing firearms these
weapons cannot be loaded with live
ammunition prop guns add authenticity by
mimicking the sound flash and recoil of
a real weapon and when a weapon uses a
blank cartridge it can still be
dangerous to achieve the flash sound and
recoil blank cartridges are filled with
gunpowder they frequently contain
something inside to seal the powder in
the case usually paper wood or plastic
called a wad and if something is inside
of the prop gun barrel it will be
expelled at nearly the same velocity as
a bullet so if a blank is discharged at
close range the wad can penetrate the
human body and this is what happened
when actor brandon lee was killed on the
set of the 1994 film the crow when there
was a dummy round stuck in the barrel
the dummy round that was used in another
scene should have been removed before
filming a close-up involving the weapon
however a 44 caliber smith and wesson
revolver had been hand loaded by someone
who wasn't a firearms expert the person
removed the propellant powder but
unknowingly left the live primer in
place this caused the bullet to be
separated from the casing without enough
energy for it to exit the barrel the gun
wasn't checked before it was used to
film a close-up and during the scene
actor michael massey pointed the gun
atlee and when he pulled the trigger the
dummy was blown out of the barrel
killing lee and the cartridges may also
result in hot exploding gas to mimic a
muzzle blast that gas can also inflict
serious injuries if fired at close range
for example in 1984 actor john eric
hexham was filming the seventh episode
of the cbs series cover-up hexham was
filming a scene where his character
loaded bullets into a 44 magnum so he
was given a functioning gun and blanks
when hexum was frustrated by a filming
delay he started playing with a gun
hexum had removed all but one blank he
put the revolver to his temple pulled
the trigger as if playing russian
roulette and although the wadding did
not penetrate his skull the force of the
blast created by the hot gas cracked his
skull and hexam died from a brain
hemorrhage and perhaps by now you've
seen the similarities between all three
of these incidents they all involve
revolvers rather than semi-automatic
pistols because the requirements for an
on-screen revolver are different than
other pistols now it's my understanding
that on a western film set like this
film crews do use real revolvers but
they use several different kinds of
ammunition the first is a blank that
contains a cartridge with gunpowder it
will shoot a flame out when you
shoot the gun but it doesn't contain an
actual bullet the casing is crimped
where the bullet would otherwise go but
since in a revolver the bullets are
exposed to the camera you need at least
one other kind of round that would be a
dummy round where it does contain the
actual bullet the round lead thing but
it doesn't contain any gun powder and so
when you depress the hammer the bullet
doesn't fire because there's nothing to
go off so at least with respect to one
of the main criticisms i've seen why
weren't they just all blanks
blanks wouldn't look right on film but
since everyone knows how dangerous prop
guns can be how could this happen should
baldwin have checked the gun himself
well given how complicated it can be to
film guns it's not as simple as
discharging live rounds it's imperative
that firearms experts check these
weapons it's also crucial for everyone
on set to observe safety protocols for
example in real life you're never
supposed to point a gun at a person but
typically on the set of a film actors
point the gun at the camera all the time
but everyone in the line of fire would
be wearing goggles and face masks they'd
also stand behind a perspex screen
hutchins and sosa were apparently
checking camera angles by looking at the
monitor when they were struck during the
process so this is a lot of background
but it's necessary to determine whether
anyone faces criminal or civil liability
as a result of what happened so let's
talk about the liability of the cast and
crew let's start with actor alec baldwin
when the shooting made headlines
baldwin's political opponents
immediately shared their thoughts and of
course it's natural to point the finger
at baldwin because he's the one that
physically pulled the trigger of the gun
in this case but there's a difference
between an accidental shooting on a
movie set and an intentional killing new
mexico criminal law defines murder as
the killing of one human being by
another without lawful justification or
excuse and we've talked about the mental
states required for murder in the first
degree which usually requires malice of
forethought which means that the
defendant planned to commit murder
without cause or provocation
manslaughter on the other hand is
defined as the quote unlawful killing of
a human being without malice because
manslaughter does not involve the mental
state of malice it's considered less
serious than murder and
mouse of forethought is a
criminal term of art that i'm not going
to go into the nuances here but it
doesn't mean anger necessarily i'm going
to assume that baldwin did not intend to
hurt anyone here so that means murder is
off the table now new mexico
manslaughter cases are classified as
either involuntary or voluntary
voluntary manslaughter involves a
killing that occurs during a quote
sudden quarrel or in the heat of passion
as far as we know that doesn't apply to
anyone on the rust film set including
baldwin the crime of involuntary
manslaughter involves a killing that
occurs in the commission of some other
unlawful act or a felony crime
involuntary manslaughter also involves a
killing that occurs while the defendant
is engaging in a lawful but dangerous
act without exercising due caution and
circumspection and an example of an
involuntary manslaughter might be a
fatal traffic accident caused by a
driver who was texting while driving and
to prove involuntary manslaughter
prosecutors must show three things first
that someone was killed as a result of
an act of the defendant second that the
act was inherently dangerous or done
recklessly and third that the defendant
should have known the act threatened the
lives of others and prosecutors don't
need to prove intent in new mexico for
involuntary manslaughter because it can
be committed recklessly or through an
inherently dangerous act and the primary
defense to involuntary manslaughter is
that it was just an accident a defendant
can show that they didn't act
irresponsibly or didn't know that their
action could have resulted in another
person's death so the question is did
baldwin act recklessly or commit an
inherently dangerous act did he violate
standard safety procedures by pointing
the gun directly at people well the
early report suggests that baldwin
didn't just pick up the gun and start
pointing it at people according to the
crew members who spoke to the los
angeles times baldwin removed the gun
from its holster once without incident
but the second time he did so ammunition
flew towards the trio around the monitor
this suggests there was something wrong
with the weapon but shouldn't baldwin
have checked the gun himself wouldn't
anyone handling a firearm check the gun
themselves well mike trisano and armor
who worked with alec baldwin in the 1998
movie thick as thieves said that
he was great to work with and was very
safe i was surprised to hear it was him
he was always on the mark and very
professional he's not stupid industry
insiders seem to indicate that it's
totally normal for an actor to rely on
the rest of the film crew to properly
handle the weapons especially when some
of the crew have explicitly told the
actor that the gun is safe to be used in
the circumstances and that probably
makes sense to delegate this
responsibility actors aren't necessarily
going to know all the ins and outs of
all the different firearms especially
when different kinds of ammunition are
used in the same scene and of course if
actors did have to recheck every firearm
that they were given that could create
even more uncertainty and allow things
to go wrong in different ways if they
didn't reload the weapon correctly so
this sort of delegation in my mind at
least as an industry standard seems like
it makes sense so under the scenario as
we know it for baldwin to be charged
he'd probably have to know that there
was a live round in the gun ahead of
time a weapons expert said once the
weapon is loaded it's impossible to tell
what's inside and trisano said that it
was not baldwin's job to check the gun
quote someone professional on set should
have been handling that gun this makes
no sense so then the only question is
whether baldwin was negligent or
reckless in handling the weapon it
doesn't seem that we have any facts to
indicate that for example he was playing
around with the gun or doing things that
someone told him not to do which is
probably what would be necessary so
although baldwin probably won't face any
criminal charges the likelihood that he
is going to be sued as a producer of the
movie is probably pretty high but it
doesn't mean that no one from the rust
film will face criminal liability is it
possible that baldwin or others could be
charged with another crime like
negligent use of a deadly weapon well
negligent use of a deadly weapon
consists of one discharging the firearm
into any building or vehicle or so as to
knowingly endanger a person or his
property to carrying a firearm while
under the influence of an intoxicant or
narcotic three endangering the safety of
another by handling or using a firearm
or other deadly weapon in a negligent
manner or for discharging a firearm
within 150 yards of a dwelling or
building now subsection 3 may be in play
in this case an early report said that
the new mexico police were trying to
determine whether the gun would be
considered quote a deadly weapon and
based on what we know about prop guns
and firing dummy rounds and the fact
that they may have actually been using
real guns with fake ammunition one would
think the answer in this case could be
yes and some members of the rust crew
have put the blame on the assistant
director a script assistant who called
9-1-1 said this [ __ ] did you see
anyone else
and yell at me he's supposed to check
the gun she's responsible for what's
happening and there are also prior
complaints about unsafe working
conditions on the rust set on october
16th the union that represents people
who work on theater and film crews
nearly went on strike over bad working
conditions the iatsi crew cited low
wages long hours and unsafe sets the
rust crew said that the set was unsafe
echoing many of the concerns that ayatse
had when it threatened to strike and
just hours before the shooting seven
camera crew members working on rust
walked off the set to protest low pay
and long hours crew members have been
told that the producers would pay for
them to stay in hotel rooms in santa fe
but when they arrived on set they were
told that they would be staying in
albuquerque that's a one-hour drive from
the film set that means that crew would
have to drive one hour to work then be
on set for 12 to 13 hours and then drive
for another hour back to albuquerque
they were allegedly only getting five
hours of sleep the crew also said their
paychecks had been delayed and three
crew members told the la times that they
were concerned with gun safety because
there had already been two accidental
prop gun discharges there were no safety
meetings there was no assurance that it
wouldn't happen again all they wanted to
do was rush rush rush one anonymous
person said that he was so alarmed by
the prop gun misfires that he sent a
text message to the unit production
manager the la times reviewed a text
message sent before the shooting that
read quote we've now had three
accidental discharges this is super
unsafe deadline cites an unnamed source
who said a gun had gone off in a cabin
while someone was holding it a gun had
two misfires in a closed cabin they just
fired loud pops a person was just
holding it in their hands and it went
off an anonymous crew member tweeted
that the crew had sent a message about
gun safety shortly before walking off
the set past and present crew members
have also spoken out against assistant
director david halls in 2019 hulls was
the assistant director for the movie
freedom's path
in that movie a gun discharge which
injured a crew member the injured man
was a boom operator who suffered inner
ear injuries hulls was fired and the
armorer was replaced the freedom's path
production company confirmed the
incident quote halls was removed from
the set immediately after the prop gun
discharged production did not resume
filming until dave was off site however
the anonymous crew member said that
there was no armor on freedom's path
that halls let a background actor take
control of the prop gun that there was
no safety meeting and that several
people asked halls if the weapon had
been cleared of ammunition and gunpowder
but halls didn't say the freedom's path
producers denied that part of the story
and now we've heard about several
incidents involving gun safety and david
halls these incidents could clearly be
relevant towards civil liability to the
producers who continued to hire hulls
and might have had notice of his past
behavior now producers from three
productions involving assistant director
halls have issued carefully worded
statements about what happened on their
sets that's because they might have
legal exposure for injuries that
happened on their projects too the cause
of action against producers would be
negligence the new mexico wrongful death
act allows monetary recovery for a death
that occurs as a result of someone's
negligence the statute provides that
party-seeking recovery can pursue an
action if legal recourse would have been
available for a personal injury and this
is something that people get wrong all
the time when someone passes away the
legal cause of action just doesn't go
away the estate can sue on behalf of the
deceased person having actual knowledge
of lack safety protocols and actual
knowledge of prior misfires is the kind
of thing that takes negligence to
actual recklessness and might go from
civil liability to criminal liability
firearms experts told variety that
actors are given fake guns until it's
time to shoot the scene when it's time
for action the actor is handed the real
gun quote it is understood that when the
firearm is handed to him it is in proper
working order and that is a
responsibility of the armorer or prop
master whoever is in control the
firearms on set if there were prior
incidents of accidental weapons
discharge on the rust set and the
assistant director knew about them but
didn't correct them or insist on greater
safety protocols it's possible that he
could be charged with involuntary
manslaughter prosecutors would need to
prove that the staff committed a lawful
but dangerous act such as handling a
prop gun and did not act with due
caution i remember to be convicted in
the state of new mexico the prosecutor
needs only to prove that someone was
quote endangering the safety of others
by handling or using a firearm or other
deadly weapon in a negligent manner and
that takes us to the person that's
responsible for maintaining the weapons
on the film set the armor the armor on
rust was the daughter of a legendary
hollywood armor and last month the
armorer told the podcast voices of the
west that she had just completed her
first film a western starring nicholas
cage her job on rust was just her second
as lead armorer she said that it's
standard to assume that no one on set
from the actors to the crew had ever
handled a weapon before and that person
explained that her philosophy was that
films should always use blanks however
she said some people really don't want
you to dummy it for some reason just out
of their own i don't know
how do you want to feel comfortable i
guess she could have been referring to
the producers directors or other prop
masters we don't know if anyone decided
to use live rounds on set the armor said
quote i think loading blanks was like
the scariest thing to me because i was
like oh i don't know anything about it
but you know he taught me that and
eventually by the time i was like trying
to figure out how to make a specific
blank
go when you wanted to rather than
hitting like the empty cylinders and
everything
figured that out on my own explain that
process uh so normally if you like you
know you open the loading gate you put
the bullet in you have to put it right
around to right before
you have to bring that bullet that blank
all the way around to right before the
cylinder so then that way the next time
someone holds back the hammer
and shoots it it'll go on
yeah and you have to like look at the
front of it and determine which one is
the blank if it's dummied up you know
that's how i tell at least the podcaster
asked if the rest of the cylinder is
generally filled with dummy wads and the
armorer said that usually it was and a
video of actor jensen ackles discussed
the gun training that he received for
the film ackles talked about gun safety
on the movie during a convention for
fans of the tv show supernatural ackles
said they had me pick my gun they were
like all right uh what what gun would
you would you like and i was like i
don't know and the armor was like you
have gun experience
like what's a gun
and i was like uh a little
and she's like okay well this is how you
load it
this is how this is how we check it make
sure it's safe i'm like okay she's like
okay i'm gonna put some blanks in there
and i want you to just go and and fire
off a couple rounds towards the towards
the hill and i was like okay so i put
the belt on i put the gun there
and i walked out and she's like just
make sure that you you know you pull the
hammer all the way back and you aim at
your target and i was like i was like
okay i got it and then i go
this statement might be relevant to the
police investigation as well as the
investigation by the state agency which
investigates workplace accidents he said
the gun was loaded with blanks and the
armor told the podcaster that that was
her strong preference this video might
also be highly relevant to the amount of
training or lack thereof that the actors
and staff received when they were
working on this film there also reports
that the crew had concerns that hannah
gutierrez read didn't have the necessary
expertise unit production manager
catherine walters sent a slack message
on october 8th that said quote
apparently props and armor require
hand-holding they claim that there were
other accidental discharges on set first
baldwin's stunt double had accidentally
fired a blank after being told that his
gun was cold reed denies that she told
the stuntman that the gun was cold she
claims that she told a man that the gun
was hot with blanks second quote a young
woman from the props department actually
shot herself in the foot that round was
a blank and following the press
conference by police hannah guterres
reid released her first statement about
the shooting according to her lawyers
the producers hired her for two roles
armorer and prop assistant she said
being the prop assistant made it
difficult for her to do her job as
armorer she said that she requested more
time for training the actors and this
was denied she also said that both she
and the prop master sarah zachary had
complete control over the guns reed told
investigators that on the day of the
shooting during lunch the firearms were
secured in a safe with a combination on
a white prop truck that only a few
people had access to but the ammunition
was left on an unsecured cart and wasn't
in a separate locked compartment reed
was adamant that there was no live ammo
on set she said she quote never
witnessed anyone shoot live rounds with
these guns nor would she permit that
after lunch reed said that zachary got
the firearms from safe during filming
she quote gave the gun to baldwin a
couple of times as well as to first
assistant director david halls reed
denied that any of the weapons were
quote unaccounted for or being shot by
crew members according to reed she
locked up the set's guns at night and
lunch sergey svetnoy was a crew member
on rust he wrote a facebook post blaming
hutchen's death on quote negligence and
unprofessionalism although he didn't
name the armorer svetnoy clearly
referred to her quote i'm sure that we
had the professionals in every
department but one the department that
was responsible for the weapons there's
no way that a 24 year old woman can be a
professional with armory professionals
are the people who have spent years on
sets people who know this job from a to
z these are the people who have the
safety on set at the level of reflexes
they do not need to be told to put the
sandbag on a tripod fix the ladder on
stage or fence off the explosion site
they have it in their blood i'm calling
out to the producers spent noise said
producers cut corners by hiring
unqualified people to save money and the
producers obviously push back on that
claim because it's not just the people
that are on set that might face civil or
criminal liability as a result of what
happened it's possible that the
producers of the movie might face
vicarious liability for the negligence
that may or may not have happened on set
or potentially negligently hiring people
who weren't capable of delivering the
safety that was required and not
surprisingly the use of firearms on set
involves extra layers of disclosure and
planning producers usually have to
submit their plans for using firearms on
set for review by insurance officials or
else it's hard to get a bond for the
production for liability purposes
baldwin was probably entitled to rely on
the assistant director yellen cold gun
but new details about the shooting
indicate that we can't totally rule out
homicide charges against the armorer and
assistant director prosecutors would
still need to show that the responsible
person had a deprived mind and in
practice this occurs when a person
intentionally engages in outrageous
reckless conduct with a total
indifference to the value of human life
however mere negligence or recklessness
isn't enough the prosecutor must prove
that the person knew their conduct was
greatly dangerous to the lives of others
an example would be a person shooting
into a crowd of people so if live
ammunition was deliberately loaded into
the firearm that was handed to baldwin
by a person who knew the gun would be
pointed at others then that could be a
murder case but more likely what we're
looking at here is a case of
manslaughter whether voluntary or
involuntary because it looks like
someone just engaged in manifest
negligence or extreme recklessness so
detectives will also take into
consideration whether there really were
two accidental discharges before the
shooting because that speaks to very
very lax protocols and if that turns out
to be true that there were many
accidental discharges which should never
happen and the assistant director or the
armor knew about this because they were
responsible for it then they might have
some serious criminal liability probably
just not a homicide and brandon lee's
family settled a lawsuit against
producers of the crow the death of
camera assistant sarah jones in a train
accident also resulted in a lawsuit in
addition to new protocols for filming on
railroad tracks i'm sure all of this
will come out in an investigation but
plaintiffs will want to know who knew
what and when were people aware that the
crew had walked out that they had
complained about safety issues did
people know about the other accidental
discharges if those actually happened
did people talk to anyone did they make
any changes in protocol there have been
thousands if not tens of thousands of
movies that have used firearms since the
brandon lee incident in the 90s and none
of them until now had resulted in
someone dying now there's still a ton
that we don't know about this incident
but it's entirely possible that someone
is going to jail over this and someone
is certainly going to pay a lot of money
but this video isn't over there is an
extended discussion of the baldwin
incident over on nebula thanks to
today's sponsor curiosity stream and i'm
thrilled to announce my first nebula
original bad law words good it's a
long-form documentary where i explore
the most common legal and linguistic
comments that people throw around in
everyday life
though they do it extremely incorrectly
so strap in because it's gonna get
really pedantic it's a hilarious romp
through legal misunderstandings logical
fallacies and law and order parodies
and it's only available on nebula which
you can get for free with curiosity
stream because nebula is a place where
we can experiment with content and do
things that we couldn't put on youtube
and we're thrilled to be partnering with
curiosity stream because they're the
go-to source for the best documentaries
and long-form educational content on the
internet they even have an entire
section devoted to unsolved mysteries
and crimes so if you like my videos you
will love the stuff on curiosity stream
and we worked out a deal where if you
sign up for curiosity stream with the
link in the description you'll also get
a nebulous subscription for free and to
be clear that nebula subscription is not
a trial it's free for as long as you're
a member of curiosity stream and right
now curiosity stream is offering 26 off
their annual plans that's less than 15
for the entire year for both curiosity
stream and nebula so if you click on the
link below you'll get curiosity stream
and nebula for 26 off or you can go to
curiositystream.com legaleagle it's a
great way to support this channel and
educational content directly and it's
the only way to see my documentary bad
law words good so just click on the link
that's on screen right now plus clicking
on that link really helps out this
channel and while you're there click on
this playlist with all of my other real
law reviews so click on this video or
i'll see you in court